the best-preserved theater from the
ancient world a theater whose lower 34
tiers of seats were created by the
classical Greeks but then were augmented
by a an additional 21 tiers of seats put
in by the Romans to make that theater at
Epidaurus surpass all others it's the
site today of a great festival every
summer of ancient dramas both comedies
and tragedies worth going to I assure
you even if you don't understand a word
of Greek for the excitement of sitting
in those seats where so many thousands
of set before you from hearing the air
echo with those ancient lines of verse
of comedy of tragedy from watching the
actors down on the stage sometimes in
very contemporary style productions and
from hearing that sublime that marvelous
acoustic somehow the Greeks captured
with a true genius the ability of stone
arranged in a semi-circle to reflect
back into the center the sound and to
derive from the center from actor
standing down at the focal point of the
theatre words which even when spoken in
a whisper had the ability to reach the
highest tiers of seats this is the magic
of epidurals and one that fortunately
you can still very much appreciate
yourself Epidaurus also gives you the
chance to see a theater in true working
trim you are seeing the complete
circular Orchestra that would have had a
little altar of Dionysus the god of the
theater standing in the middle around
that Orchestra is a great trough cut in
the stone laid down in the masonry a
theater this big which is open to the
sky is in wintertime going to shed a lot
of water this trough was a very
practical method for dealing with all of
the runoff and carrying it away the
Greek engineers at work but the
engineers were at work in another area
too opposite the spectators on the far
side of the circle of the orchestra
where the chorus would sing and dance
the actors would come down and play
their parts is the rectangular skin a
building the ske any word from which we
get seen and behind it there was a
gigantic mechanism called the crane in
fact our word machine mechanic comes
from the Greek word for crane Makani
because this crane was one of the most
impressive pieces of machinery and
engineering in the Greek world and it
was applied as so much of our technology
is not to warfare or to commerce but to
the entertainment industry these cranes
would lift up actors swing them up and
over the roof of the skinny building the
scene building and hang them out over
the stage to the left and the right were
the chorus with their separate entrances
each one called a parados in front of
them spread the tiers of seats that they
could look out to and then speaking as
gods they would declaimed the end of the
play they would wrap up the action they
would deal out fates and fortunes to the
various principal characters of the
drama in Latin the word for one of these
figures flown in on the great crane was
deus ex machina god from the machine and
so we still use that phrase today for
any work of art be it a movie or a stage
play or a novel that drags in by the
hair of its head without any proper
reason for being rationale someone who
will with the twinkling of an eye and
the wave of a wand fix whatever the
dramatic problem is so that the work of
art can end that's our deus ex machina
but for the Greeks it was a moment of
Epiphany a words which means shining
forth as the God appeared floating
flying above the stage in what must have
been some of the most dramatic moments
anyone has ever seen in a theatre you
can play a role at Epidaurus there's an
International Folk Festival on that site
every day that it's open to tourists go
out to the sweet spot in the center of
the circle today marked by a stone take
your turn and then stand there as many
others will have stood before you and do
what they have done sing a song
recite a poem express feelings for a
distant loved one but speak your piece
you too will have the thrill of knowing
that your friends up in the tears are
hearing that magic acoustic carry your
ordinary normal tone of voice way up to
the very top of this great theater